يقول غاري من فرجينيا إن هذا يقول
أنني قد تلقيت لقاحًا كاملاً اعتبارًا من مايو 2021.
لم أعد أشعر بالحماية بعد الآن ، ربما
يمكنك معالجة ذلك وأريد أن
تكون
اللقاحات الأصلية سارية المفعول قبل ثمانية أشهر
أو أكثر أو ننتظر جرعة معززة
عندما تنخفض فعالية
لقاحاتنا ، فلماذا علينا أن ننتظر
جيدًا حتى يكون هذا سؤالًا رائعًا
وما قالته فرق العمل المرموقة في الأساس
هو أنهم أشاروا إلى أننا
نرى بعض إشارات الأمان فيما يتعلق
بتضاؤل الأجسام المضادة ، لذا فهم يح
ولون  لتكون استباقيًا ، لذا ربما لا تنتظر حتى
يروا عدد حالات دخول المستشفى
وأشياء من هذا القبيل ترتفع ،
سنرى كيف يتعامل كل من cdc و fda مع
هذا لأنه لا يزال يتعين أن يمر
عبر العمليات الرسمية ثم
يتم التوصية به رسميًا من قبل cdc
و  في الوقت الحالي ، أنت تعلم أنني يجب أن أقول إن
اللقاحات لا تزال تعمل جيدًا حقًا ،
نتحدث كثيرًا عن الأجسام المضادة التي تجعل الناس
يهتمون أكثر بالمرضى أكثر من
دمائهم ، دعني أوضح لك شيئًا من
ai أحب عرض رسومات كهذه
لأنني أعتقد أنها تروي قصة
ما حدث مع اللقاحات
بشكل عام
، الخط المتقطع الذي تراه يتصاعد
في الزاوية اليمنى العليا هناك وهو
الأشخاص غير الملقحين في المستشفى
هذا يمر بنهاية  الشهر الماضي
ويمكنك أن ترى أن المحصلة النهائية
مسطحة تقريبًا مقابل الأسفل ،
هناك اللقاحات التي لا تصدق والتي
تم تطعيمها جزئيًا حتى أعلى قليلاً من
ذلك ، أريد فقط الاستمرار في عرض هذه
الرسومات لأننا نتحدث عن
المعززات وكل شيء ويقول الناس
جيدًا إن لقاحاتي هي  تتلاشى
من حيث الأشياء الأكثر أهمية ،
فهي في الحقيقة ليست
فعالة جدًا لبعض الوقت ، إلى
متى ستستمر ، لا أعتقد أنه يمكننا أن
نقول على وجه اليقين ولكن في الماضي كنت تعلم أن
هناك لقاحات يمكنها  آخر ما عرفته
منذ سنوات وتحصل على معززات بين الحين والآخر ،
لذا سنرى ما إذا كان هذا يشبه
الإنفلونزا أو أكثر من هذا القبيل